An Arizona mother who was
recently the victim of a deepfake
kidnapping extortion
plot is joining us
to talk about that scam
that used her daughter's
voice and demanded money
$1,000,000 in ransom money.
At one point,
Jennifer DeStefano testified
before Congress this week
to sound the alarm
on the danger
of artificial intelligence,
urging lawmakers
to regulate this uncharted territory
before something
this happens to another family.
There's
it was my daughter's voice.
It was her cries, it was her sobs.
It was the way she spoke.
I will never be able to shake that voice.
And the desperate cries for help
out of my mind
is every parent's worst nightmare
to hear your child pleading with fear
and pain,
knowing that they're being harmed
and that you're helpless.
The longer
this form of terror
remains unconditional,
the farther and more egregious
it will become.
There is no limit to the depth of evil
I can enable.
Jennifer DiStefano and her
daughter Bree are joining us now.
And Bree, for people
who are not familiar with your story,
I do want to point out
you are safe,
but you have always been safe.
You were never in danger here,
Jennifer, though
you had no way of knowing that
when you got this phone call
We hear the emotion in your voice
there from your testimony.
Just walk us through, though,
if you would,
what those moments were like for you
when you thought your daughter's life
was hanging in the balance
Yeah, I was terrorized
and even hearing myself speak
and it still brings tears to my eyes.
It was absolutely terrorized.
And I was so helpless
and I didn't know which way to turn.
I didn't know what to do.
And I could hear her begging and crying.
For me, it was fear in the background.
You had other children around.
There were some
there were some friends around.
They were able to get in touch
with your husband,
get in touch
with your daughter, confirm
that she was okay, that in fact,
it wasn't her voice buried.
You have any idea how these scammers
may have gotten a hold of your voice?
Because they certainly use
it to convince your mom
I actually
have no
idea,
because we've tried to trace this
all the way back to my social media, but
I really do not post videos of me
using my actual voice.
And if I did, they were
from when I was younger,
and I have a premature voice.
My voice is higher,
but now I only post videos of me
really just competing in sports,
nothing of me actually using my voice.
So it's really still mystery to this day.
Does that scare you at all, Bree?
It does scare me
because
if they can get my voice in which voice
I want to know, then
what else could they do with my family?
What could I do with my mom?
If they have their location,
that they have my location,
how can they get things
and information out of this?
And Jennifer,
I know you're searching
for those answers.
The police said there was nothing
they could do at the time
because no crime
had actually taken place.
What has it changed, though, for
your family?
It definitely opened my eyes.
I had no idea
the level of capabilities,
but I
we've had a lot of conversations about
you can't believe everything
you see, everything you hear
a family code word, some different types
of security measurements now that we use.
And I'm also really hesitant
when if I don't recognize a number
or someone reaches out to me,
even when AT&T reach out to me to try and
find out
some more information
about this,
I didn't respond to them for weeks
because I don't know who was really who
and what's really real.
And sometimes it's
scary to even pick up your phone
because there's a concern.
I'm sure we've all heard that
if you say hello, then all of a sudden
they may have your voice.
When you testified before Congress.
Do you feel that you
were heard by lawmakers
I do.
I was
very happy
that all sides
have come together on this.
So it gives me a lot of hope
that it's a unified mission
Senator also took it upon himself
to call the Scottsdale
Phenix Police Department and ask them
what kind of protocol
they have for other victims of this.
And they said, again,
they were not able to do anything since
no crime was committed.
And he made a personal commitment
that that will stop.
So I do feel like
this is actually finally being heard
and that actions can be taken.
Do you have a sense of what that action
may be?
Did they give you any indication
There's been
a couple of different conversations,
everything from watermarking
so that they have traceability.
It's really hard to
trace it at the moment.
Some different types of things.
It's really hard
to put your hands around
exactly what can be done in the sense
that is so vast and so wide
and what's already out there
and how do you dial it back.
So a lot of
is trying to get ahead of it,
but there's a couple
of different opportunities out there.
You mentioned,
you know, what you post now,
what you used to post
that this confusion
and the big mystery over
how they got your voice.
How has this impacted you if it has
and the way you go about your daily life
This is impacting me
in my everyday life
just by being more cautious, you know,
I'm more tedious, just even going out
places by myself
or just having that plan of action,
you know, like
what if this actually does happen?
Just having things with me for protection
and just being more aware
Jennifer Embry DeStefano,
really appreciate
you taking the time
to join us this morning
and to share your story.
I know it is so painful,
but also so helpful for so many families.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for having so much,
Poppy. Erica, thank you.
What do you think, John?
Well, this is game
changing in so many ways between
you can already imagine
going into a political season,
you know, about the fakes and deep fakes
that are going to be available,
you know, from A.I.
You can
then attach that to
moisture here on the ground to
what are the Russians
and the North Koreans
and the Chinese is going to do with that.
But if you get right down
to a crime like this,
this is
I mean, the
story they just told about a parent
hearing the phone
ring and hearing their child
crying in the background and saying,
I messed up, you know, I need help.
And then there's voice coming on.
So the kids here are
the object of that person
who is demanding this money.
Their job is to keep you
on the phone unbroken.
They want you to
they want you to transfer
funds to all kinds
that they don't want you
to pick up the phone and find out
your daughter is really upstairs
in her room doing your homework.
So the first thing is, you know,
to figure out,
does this have the signs
of one of these scams?
And this story is really important
in recognizing that,
you know, you want to say, okay,
I'm not sure this is real.
Ask her what her
cousin Kelly's dog name is.
You know, things
that they haven't factored in their
The technology is really affecting
crime in ways that are so unanticipated.
I had a kidnaping in the NYPD
where the person, you know, was missing
and the ransom demands were coming in
and we were looking for a ransom drop,
you know, with airplanes
and surveillance team.
And it turns out the ransom was to be
sent by Bitcoin.
So now you don't have
a ransom drop and we're like Bitcoin.
What do we do with that
in terms of figuring out
where the kidnapers were, the victims?
So these challenges will keep coming.
And the issue with legislation
is to legislate against it.
You have to first understand it.
And we're just archiving the surface.
It's a sad reality.
Anytime there's a new technology
criminals swarm to it and weaponize it,
and then it becomes
an arms race between law enforcement,
figuring it out, catching up
a public education is a key part of that.
Right.
And I think that that's very helpful.
Even just to hear about those experiences
that they just had.
It's so interesting you say have
have that word.
I mean, I think about, you know,
our kids are all around the same age.
And we have a word of if you need me
to pick you up at a party
and you don't want your friends to know,
you just let me know, right?
This is your
I won't embarrass you as your parent.
This is where you need
that same word of I'm going to ask
that word on the phone to know
if it's you to the point of politicians,
you need to understand this.
Will Hurd was telling us
in the break, former congressman,
this is something that he's
really leaning into.
Do you see politicians leaning into this?
Because Americans are concerned about it?
Yeah.
I mean,
are they going to be able
to speak to it, too,
in the way that they need to
and is informed
that they need to be there
doing their homework right now
and they're playing
catch up in a lot of ways.
But you had the White House,
you had a meeting with President
Biden and Vice President Kamala Harris.
They were meeting with the top
CEOs of these technology companies.
Trying to figure out where
what the risks are and the benefits
because they feel like the benefits
do outweigh the risks,
but the risks are there.
You think something that's different now
than during social media?
Mark Zuckerberg,
when he started Facebook, the motto
and it was his own words, move
fast and break things.
And then obviously he's reassessed since.
But that is not how someone like
Sam Altman at OpenAI.
The creative chat is approaching this.
It's very different.
And he and others are calling
for rules of the road regulation
now, not after they've taken heat,
but now. Should that give us some hope?
I think so.
I think they're starting
to take it seriously.
But you're just seeing the machine moving
right now
and Congress is having hearings.
The White House is holding meetings.
So you're seeing it kind of in motion.
But stay tuned. I think more to come.
Thank you guys, very, very much.